I'll never forget playing RuneScape back
when I was a kid it is the goat but in
2023 why is the older version of the
game old school RuneScape significantly
more popular than RuneScape 3. well
that's because the game's developer
jagex did basically everything in their
power to kill the game they removed PVP
combat from the Wilderness and replaced
it with other game modes then they got
rid of the ability to trade freely
but the final nail in the coffin was the
evolution of combat update they wanted
to bring RuneScape more in line with
other MMOs like wow but literally nobody
asked and if there's one thing that this
Boomerang Community does not like
in 2013 they started coming back when
jagex released a 2007 version of the
game since then old school RuneScape has
always been more popular than the more
modern version RuneScape 3. a reminder
that just because it's new doesn't mean
it's better